une marche des sans papiers aujourd'hui
dans la capitale française une
manifestation qui a débuté place de la
république et des protestataires qui
réclament la régularisation des sans
papiers la fermeture des centres de
rétention administratif ainsi qu'un
logement pour les étrangers un mouvement
qui intervient dans le prolongement
d'une mars lancé le 19 septembre dernier
à marseille et dans d'autres métropoles
de l'hexagone et coûté nous avons
organisé une marche des sans papiers une
marche nationale des sans-papiers depuis
le 19 septembre
et ça a démarré entre marseille et
montpellier
nous avons démarré montpellier marseille
parce que nous avons rejoint nos
camarades de marseille et montpellier
nous l'air les collectifs de paris pour
qu'on nous une convergence ensemble et
marcher ensemble pour arriver
aujourd'hui à paris nous avons des
objectifs des revendications à athènes
c'est la fermeture des centres de
rétention administratif ya la
régularisation sans conditions de toutes
et tous les sans papiers les logement
décentes pour toutes et tous et la
liberté de circulation et d'installation
cela il va avec nos revendications
ça fait depuis 2004 parce que je suis là
et j'ai eu des papiers
je les ai perdus et actuellement je suis
toujours je suis en demander pardon